[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
really get real footage brother
and I wanted to either play on fight
one fight stick over there
those guys suck terribly
[Music]
like an orientation like if you were
so okay this is the natural evolution of
samurai shodown 64 they came out only in
RK
made into a home iteration
yeah we're supposed to be on a Neo Geo
64 system they had like three games this
is the natural evolution of it I see a
lot of high-res 4k graphics let's go see
classic battle
versus paisa
kinda seems to be
sovereign seems happy having a problem
throwing out his tornado
no problems whatsoever
using his charge rules and his
projectiles
my eyes there seems to have the upper
hand in the match you
it takes over
age I believe is definitely a fact
as much guys it looks like he is sharp
but again muscle memory
sovereign always kicks in
it looks like he's going for the jugular
with the ripping and the tearing
we ask is there anything left in the
tank for sovereign
[Music]
old-school beat downs tournament
all sovereign has found his magic moves
he turned the world red at no avail
Kizer is moving back into position
please mortally wounded sovereign is
showing the old form
he is going for the jugular folks
[Music]
tap tempo kick yank and that normally
would have been the death of him
type Otsu shows the fighter spirit and
heart of you will be served this day
[Music]
but the jaws of the feed victory is we
have one one brother versus brother
sovereign loves his up slash he's using
it in the sidestep to perfection
the clash of swords still versus steel
beautiful counter
[Music]
Tatsu is going for the jugular
oh whoa
the battle is raging on as they go tit
for tat hit for hit a battle for the
ages sovereign has definitely doing a
shot he is back in business old forms
are showing it is telling
can he make Kaiser remember the olden
days can he turn back the hands of time
as father time come and crushed his
gamer skill
soon any folks as sovereign battles for
his gaming mortality
all school concussions convulsion
he brought it back and now King steps
into the arena to fight sovereigns
is so much more animation
but it does still have kind of like a
stiffness to it so that way is like you
have to really think about what movie
you're gonna do
you have anything to say to the viewers
before the fight
$200
and $60 CDs there was a one time see
with the juggling monkey when now they
give you the running rabbit ha ha ha
and it looks like they're actually
taking it to the captain
[Music]
[Music]
you see Lord can you play again Jerome
no sanas harborough again right now he's
taking reserved stance shooting out
projectiles
[Music]
and derozan he bowed and he's going on
the attack
[Music]
Oh
the back
yes
a very favorite every Bogardus
neck-and-neck
after that go
only for me now and you have a hair
folks
they got fatalities